when you're thinking about starting a
company right
what kind of qualities do you need to
have as an individual right what
characteristics make a great founder i
could ask this a lot when i'm teaching
angel university or i'm talking to
investors uh or people just ask me the
press whatever hey how do you how are
you so good at picking companies well
let's be honest i picked 350 companies
there's got to be a couple of uh
unicorns in there if you're going to
pick that many but there are some
characteristics that are super uh
important now one of the things you'll
hear over and over again and the
question you have to ask yourself is and
this one relates really to motivation
are you solving a problem that has
personal relevance to you are you super
passionate about this idea and do you
really care about seeing this product or
service manifest itself in the real
world and are you willing to give up a
decade of your life because that's what
it takes and if the problem is not
important to you right let's say you
decide you want to create slack and you
think chat and talking to people and
communications at companies is just
something that has been burning you for
a long time because you've worked at
companies where you've been sitting in
meetings and wasting time great you're
going to wake up every day and you're
going to say i really want to see this
problem stop now conversely if you like
video games you don't like working in an
office and and your thing is dungeons
and dragons and diablo and other kind of
you know real-time strategy games
whatever it is well if we put you in
charge of slack and building you know
the greatest version of slack or yammer
in the world you're going to wake up one
day and you're not going to want to do
it so
if you pick the right idea then you
don't have to worry about motivation
because you're just absolutely thrilled
to wake up every day and do your job how
do i know this well you know i'm 50
years old now i'm an entrepreneur for a
long time and i wake up every day i
can't wait can't wait to tape the
podcast and i can't wait to invest in
companies and i can't wait to do events
i love these three things i like
communicating i like talking to smart
people i like placing bets it fits who i
am so it took me decades to figure out
exactly what i wanted to do every day
but this is it and i'm super happy and i
don't have to worry about my motivation
okay
so
um there this some people refer to this
as your north star your mission
your purpose in life there's a lot of
different words for the same thing but
let's just put it in one basic simple
lens are you going to be motivated every
day for a decade to work on this problem
for robinhood it's democratizing finance
for calm it's really helping everyone
out there have more equanimity in their
life aid sleep they want to improve
sleep obviously
so
is the problem worth solving to you
and is it really really really something
you could see yourself working on for
many years
if the startup goes well
it's going to take 10 20 years to really
um hit the good moments right when you
really do change the world i mean you're
11 as an investor
and uh i woke up today actually just
coincidentally and i realized you know
what we're at 9 000 members in the
syndicate the syndicate.com my angel
syndicate and i had set this stretch
goal of hitting ten thousand when i
wrote the book three years ago angel
and i'm just realized i'm about to hit
it and i was like wow gotta have some
sort of celebration then somebody said
hey do you know what this next deal we
do we're gonna break a hundred million
dollars invested from the syndicate and
i was like
wow you know my goals are starting to
manifest themselves
in year 10 or 11. that's what it takes
actually the syndicate is more like year
7 right i've been angel investing for
11. so make sure you pick something that
is really passionate to you uh because
if you're in it to just get rich or be
famous or to have the title of ceo
founder i can tell you that those things
are not enough to get you to get out of
bed in the morning when you open your
phone
and one email says resignation in the in
the subject line and it's from one of
your top contributors and your just
stomach syncs oh god i just lost my cto
i just lost my
you know
head of hr and human capital oh my god
you know it's just that's like getting
punched in the gut or the lawsuit shows
up and you get a legal letter oh my god
we're suing you
ugh you know like to get through those
moments or you look at the bank balance
and it's like oh my god we the funding
is running out
and i emailed our existing investors
asked them for a bridge and they said no
like think about those three moments
somebody who's a key contributor quits
your investors give up on you
and you get sued
think about those three different
moments would you be able to wake up and
go to work and stay focused and build
the company if that happened
now have all three happen in the same
goddamn week because that's what
entrepreneurship is those three things
it always comes in three will happen to
you in the same week and you know what
the idea of getting rich or being famous
or having the title means nothing when
you get punched in the stomach you fall
to your knees somebody kicks you in the
teeth and you know and then they stomp
on your head that's what being an
entrepreneur is like that's the reality
of it so make sure you pick an idea that
you are motivated to see through for a
decade in the face of insurmountable
odds
okay let's go on to the second question
you have to ask yourself all right
so first you know it's just an idea that
you can work on for a decade second
can you build a great product or not
can you build a great product or not
because all startups
are about building a great
world-changing product you cannot
cannot have a successful startup
based on your vision your ideas that's
not how this works
what happens is everybody has the same
goddamn ideas everybody has the same
vision you get zero points for your
vision and your ideas what do you get
points for your ability to build a
product or service that delights
customers
so let's take a deep look in the mirror
are you a developer do you know how to
write code because
that seems to be the big skill involved
in building these companies is being a
developer okay you're not a developer
are you a product manager do you know
how to manage a product and have you
done that before to coordinate between
design developers etc ux
oh you're not so you're not a developer
and you're not a product manager okay
wait there might be other things that
involve you building okay are you a ui
ux designer
so do you know what the users want and
do you know how to build the wireframes
and then go to the developers and say
here are the stories here's the product
journey do you even know what ux and ui
is if you don't
now we've established you're not the
product manager you're not the ux ui
you're not the developer
are you a designer that's kind of the
fourth one can you make a beautiful
product are you johnny ive uh you know
and um if you're not
pause for a second
and then just say well what if i was
what if you were one or two of those
things what if you were a product
manager developer ux ui designer or just
a straight up designer right
then there's industrial design there's
different types of dynamics graphic
design et cetera
you can learn these for free on the
internet
so have one of these skills and being a
product manager a ux ui designer is
probably
the quickest and easiest to learn being
a designer or developer that could take
years to be good at but being a product
manager ux ui designer you can learn in
i would say three to six months and have
a
you know be relatively good at it and
then after six to 12 months be very good
at it
whereas a developer to be very good
let's be honest that might be a two
three four year journey and to be a
designer to be a very good designer
could be five six seven year journey i
think i might argue that elite design is
it takes a little bit longer
and let's be honest a lot of times when
you're doing elite design you can hire
somebody
listen right now linkedin is gonna give
you a hundred dollar credit towards your
first ad campaign that's a hyundy for
you to get new customers to run some ads
just go to linkedin.com
checklist linkedin.com
checklist and get a hundred dollar
credit right now now let's look at your
startup let's pretend you're about to
launch a campaign it tested well your
entire team is happy the creative's
great it's going according to plan but
you have this thought in the back of
your head and you should have this
thought for a reason how do i ensure the
people i want to target will be in the
mindset to receive my message well the
answer is linkedin why because when you
mark it on linkedin your message reaches
people who are ready to do
business linkedin equals business
business equals linkedin linkedin
business business linkedin we all know
that's the case if you're there you're
doing business right and that means your
advertising campaign will work as hard
as they can as soon as you launch it
because there are over 62 million
business decision makers on linkedin
right now waiting for you that's why
over 78 of b2b marketers rate linkedin
as the most effective social media
platform at helping their organization
achieve specific goals so do business
where business is done and get a hyundy
100 ad credit at this very new domain
name linkedin.com checklist linkedin.com
check list one word terms and conditions
apply because they're giving you a hundy